okay Lisa so I saw in the morning this
morning sleeping in your furniture
blanket on the sidewalk is that where
you sleep every night
no where do you know this different
places attached street well but
basically on the sidewalk yeah telling
you been here on Skid Row nine years
nine years and where your conversion
plum Beach Long Beach what would got you
into this situation
dad's trading it down here I'm sorry I
got stranded up here you have left me
stranded out here who left you stranded
one of my friends he's no longer my
friend
yeah you just took you here and dumped
you and that's it great what problems
are you having earlier on before my mom
kicked me out what else touching your
mom kicked you out on your 13 yeah why
is that
because I was bringing too many guys
over there at 13
yeah so you're very promiscuous a ton of
the age
yeah well I guess I got a right by chat
five and ten by my road dad my stepdad
you real bad and you're stuck gun yeah
both had sex with you that what it
climate a five and then ten
[Music]
would somebody tell me about like
where'd you go at that age when you your
mom takes about think the place you go
Claire home I'm sorry secretary call
Claire and all the Claire gone Claire at
all
we're just a place where they put
youngsters when they take away from
their family
Morrison EPSS so you live there yeah
without any parents yeah for how long
when chillin I'm sorry
the tally was on yeah what a certain age
that I just like disagree yeah
Katie routine and then 818 where'd you
go oh nice tree
and tell me what it's like living on the
streets
it's no fun on your own I mean still fun
what kind of stuff going for your food
your Panhandle for food what kind of
stuff happens to you here on the street
wait how many times are good right to me
[Applause]
I've had a guy put a nine-millimeter up
my [ __ ]
how many times do you think you can
write too many free buffeting
[Applause]
okay you ate any of the drugs that are
here on the street no drugs yeah
okay what snow a little smoke this flash
joy that's it well you're not heavily
addicted on that as laughing and your
when you were being molested as the
fiber is a preteen I mean what what did
your mom did you must believe me too
that's a rough childhood okay
how do you see the world I mean do you
see the world as it is a good place to
do you see us I mean two people are in
it I mean it's a way your people are in
it
you're me the wrong with me people at
every yeah people but what do you have
to see for your future where D like to
be in five years ten mellon place your
own place
really the shelters that we had none of
the shelters
I'm scared the food there's poison the
food there the poison of them what do
you think they put in the food some kind
of poison until you get sick so where do
you wrap it like I said I paid a little
for my food do you drink it on
turtles and stuff test about it
it's almost time to come back yeah I'll
take you back missing tell me about your
family are they still around I have a
family you're not dead
my mom tears my mom my grandma's dead
everybody else - did you mention your
brother yeah he's an [ __ ]
that was sister - she killed my
grandmother she's in now so true
your friends are waiting until back cuz
I don't feel good okay let me take you
back thank you for talking to me yeah
[Music]
you